welcome back everyone to episode number
8 of the beginner to master speedrun I'm
currently rated
745 and in honor of getting to episode 8
I've changed my profile picture to a
time where I was 8 years old actually
played my first chess tournament when I
was eight so um as I progress with
episodes I think I'll be changing my
profile picture to show how I've
progressed through time but uh yeah
anyway let's get into it I'm gonna hop
into the 10-minute pool and I am playing
Bradley 23
raw let's play
E4 and okay opponent's rated
830 so yeah my opponents are gradually
getting higher rated so we might see uh
more more common more kind of
competitive openings I'll play the
italion bishop to
C4 and we have the two knights now I
could go for Knight G5 this is uh
perhaps the beginning of a fried liver
but I'm going to be solid play D3 this
is probably what I would have played at
8 years old and um yeah it's a more kind
of slow and steady approach now black
plays A6 here
which strikes me as a little bit
odd uh usually like if White's playing
the Spanish then A6 makes sense to
attack the bishop but in this
case I think I'm just going to get a a
free move of
development um and now Knight
G5 maybe makes a bit more sense CU I
think D3 is a lot more useful than A6 we
imagine Knight to
G5 uh if black plays D5 I can
take and usually the best move there is
Knight
A5 but because my Bishop is already
defended I could play Knight C3 and try
and hold on to the pawn so I think I
will go for Knight G5 now Knight G5 is
not always uh the move to go for uh
usually it's it's not great if black can
respond by castling to defend the Pawn
With The Rook but in this
case yeah there's not too many ways to
actually save the
pawn and uh I think maybe black will be
very soon regretting having played A6
rather than developing
so we'll see what the opponent does
here yeah we do see D5 I'll take it and
there is a pretty well-known tactical
sequence uh this is very similar to the
fried liver uh which is without the
inclusion of D3 and A6 uh so these pawns
were back we would be in a very
well-known position and I'm going to go
ahead and just take on F7 just relying
on the fact that uh i' I've seen this
tactical sequence before and the idea is
after the king takes I mean there's
really not too many options for black
otherwise I'll win the queen or The Rook
so King takes F7 I'll respond with Queen
F3
check uh but that's not happening wow
Queen
F6 allowing me to either take the Rook
or take the
Knight do I want the cake or the ice
cream I can only have one at least one
at a time I mean taking the
Knight actually seems a little bit more
attractive because then I keep the
attack on the rook and I defend my
knight if I take the Rook immediately
then maybe there's cases where my knight
gets stuck in the corner so yeah let's
take the
Knight I'm imagining my opponent will
play Bishop C5 and thre checkmates and
then maybe say oh no my Rook uh then The
Rook will be poisonous so if Bishop C5
yeah it's very important to be hyper
alert of the danger in the position and
I would probably respond with castling
or queen E2 or even Queen F3 I think
there'd be a a few different acceptable
moves
there now it's possible my opponent will
also try and save The Rook with Rook to
G8 but then that will give me time to
maybe keep attacking like maybe play
Bishop G5 with the
queen um but now yeah I definitely don't
want to play Bishop G5 definitely don't
want to take the
Rook uh castling I think is my top
option Queen E2 is also fine defending
and maybe aligning with the King uh but
I don't want to be in a spot where my
queen is tied down to defending I'd
rather maybe someday get the queen to H5
and use it as an attacking piece
so castling it
is and what's interesting here is black
could legally
Castle sometimes at the beginner level
there's confusion with when you can
castle and when you can't Castle but
when The Rook is attacked it doesn't
stop you from castling it's only when
the king is attacked or one of these
squares is
controlled uh but we see my opponent
just completely
ignore the king side centralizing the
Knight and now yeah it's a question do I
just take the free rook is there
anything black can do
to hurt me I don't think so let's take
the
rook and it's always important to like
double and triple check to make sure the
opponent's not threatening anything but
F7 is really the main target which is
well defended here and the Knight can't
really move forward without being
taken meanwhile yeah maybe maybe Queen
H5 is
coming so I'm up a rook and a knight and
a pawn I forgot about the pawn that I
won uh much earlier so up a lot of
material here but you can never
celebrate too
early um black does have decently active
pieces but it's hard to actually like
orchestrate much of an attack black
could try Bishop G for to deflect my
queen away from defending C2 but I think
that I'd be happy to take the bishop so
we see
C6 and I mean the natural move is
probably to
retreat Bishop F7 looks a little bit
interesting Bishop F7 King
f8 I don't know if I'm achieving so much
there I mean I do get initiative like
black would have to move the king rather
than playing a more aggressive
move
so yeah perhaps it's a it's a fine
choice and there's also cases where if
the king moves to one of these squares
then I'll be very much inclined to make
some tactics work along the the dark
Square diagonal uh but we do see King
f8s and I think from here it's a matter
of just continuing developing like this
is a weird construction my knight is in
the corner it's defending the bishop
which is sandwich between the king and
the queen but I think I'm okay leaving
everything as is and just bringing in uh
another piece and with Knight C3 I'm not
only developing and controlling the
center but I'm preparing Knight E4 which
would be really nice to centralize a
knight and now triple forking a queen
pawn and
Bishop this Pawn is attacked twice by
the Knight and
Bishop I guess I should have realized
with G5 black was threatening to take
the
Knight I maybe I'm losing back a little
bit of material because after
takes I take the bishop black takes my
Bishop then I'm only up a
rook but only being up a rook is is kind
of like only having a ton of money being
in a very comfortable spot
so uh yeah I really don't mind trading
here and now yeah now I think it's time
to play Queen H5 start harassing The
King The Queen Is Now cornered these
pieces still undeveloped Bishop is ready
to come in most likely with check like
if the king moves to E7 or
F6 uh the king could try and
retreat but I mean if I want to I could
pre-move Bishop takes G5 we'll see where
black goes
first yeah King
f8 I don't think there's any reason to
throw in another check it gives back
time to try and use a queen as a
Defender so let's take the pawn
and at this point I'm already looking
for ways to create some mating that like
I have the bishop and queen Knight kind
of swarming
around can use this shark metaphor again
maybe I'll have to put in the Jaws
music um yeah the lone King is a bit
stranded F4 may be coming another shark
will maybe have a nice
Feast a 96
[Music]
96 Queen
H6 feels like I'm almost like almost
winning something by force I could play
Bishop H6
[Music]
to I think this is a spot where I don't
want to take too long I just want
to
simplify um I kind of like
like a lot of things here what to do
let's play Bishop
H6 ensuring the Knight can't take the
bishop the Queen Camp lock probably see
King
[Music]
E7 I'm
thinking a nice approach is simply to
trade and then attack
Theon let's go for
that going to play Rook a to
E1 it's it does seem weird
putting this Rook on E1 rather than the
other Rook cuz now this Rook has no
legal moves but I'm imagining there
might be a case where I play F4
especially if there's going to be a pin
along the E
file uh but meanwhile there's really no
great looking way for black to defend E5
maybe with the exception of King D6 it's
only move to defend the pawn another
time uh but then surely the king
should be more of a
Target and if we do see King
D6 maybe then I play F4 just Target the
pawn if the trade happens then Bishop
will come in with check and then both
files will be
open we see Queen
G8 all right let's uh snag
upon opponent is resisting like I'm
trying to win quickly here but uh it
takes a little bit more work the other
Rook will come
in and if I can create the battery on
the file
then yeah there's not going to be too
much hope for black to
defend um it's a nice thing about having
the extra material
is I just uh yeah I have one more piece
to attack
with then maybe a move like Bishop F4
coming like sometimes in these spots you
want to look for the forcing moves like
the checks but all the checks that I
have just lose
material there's really
no great looking checks so move like
Bishop to
F4 just sets up a load of discoveries uh
like Rook G5 or Rook E8 both of which
will be
check I guess the one thing I should
have mentioned is if my opponent didn't
take on A2 and played Bishop
D5 then Bishop F4 lose the game due to
Queen takes G2 so I still have to be
aware
of of how I could lose the game and
sometimes this is a good kind of mental
exercise is when you're completely
winning you just want to take a moment
and ask yourself like how can I possibly
lose this position and that will
hopefully allow you to avoid uh making a
fool of yourself cuz really the only way
white can lose here is if I allow a
Checkmate on G2 or somehow I allow a
back rank mate like if somehow The Rook
black Rook comes to uh the back rank but
that's not going to
happen and from here I see Checkmate
in three moves get three
moves maybe two moves a queen does a
nice job swinging across the
board and it's funny I hear ambulance
noises in the background uh someone call
ambulance for my
opponent but uh it was a nice game um
yeah my opponent I think got a little
bit of I don't careless or just played a
little bit inaccurately in the opening
and then just immediately walked into
trouble and I guess I didn't really have
time to explain the main idea behind
Knight takes F7 uh but the idea was if
King takes which is what most people
would play Then Queen F3 check
and now the the queen attacks the king
and the Knight black would like to play
Knight F6 but the Knight is pinned so uh
black is already in big trouble here if
King G8 then White's just mating like
there's no way to escape the and then
evitable checkmates and if King to E6
this would be the best try for black and
this does actually save the piece but
after Knight to
C3 uh the position is much preferable
for white there's three attackers
against a pin Knight on
D5 and yeah even if black defends it
with Knight E7 I think a move like
castling and Rook E1 and white has full
compensation for uh being down a little
bit of material so hopefully an
important lesson to take away and yeah
maybe at some point like during the
series if I encounter this opening again
I'll play Knight G5 and if after this
this this this is uh I think known to be
like the main fry liver variation and
it's the same exact idea with inclusion
of A6 D3 I think White's already more
for Choice cuz Bishop has nice
development but um yeah as black you
either have
to know this line well like play D5 take
and then know the move Knight A5 or in
this position uh black should have just
played Bishop C5 and this is a case
where if Knight G5 castling black
defends F7 and the game goes on so um
hope there's some lessons to take away
from that game let's do another
one um new 10 game
and playing sheru rated
783 I'm white
again are we're going to see the same
opening fry liver Deja Vu okay we see
Bishop C5 so this is more of a a
mainstream Italian and in this line uh
D3 is still completely acceptable mainly
looking to complete development and I'm
going to stick with an opening that I
played when I was like seven and eight
years old which is maybe not the most
exciting looking
position uh basically a Four Knights now
that's funny my opponent is going for
this attack uh feels like we see this a
ton at uh this rating level um but
compared to last game I'm I'm in time to
Castle to defend my Eon and black is
basically wasting time moving the knight
uh cuz most cases it's not going to be
good for black to trade on F2 uh the two
minor pieces are more valuable than the
Rook so Knight D4 is an interesting move
uh does offer the trade of knights I
mean the first thing that comes to mind
is I can take the
Knight and then attack the undefended
Knight on
G4 and that is one of the downsides of
putting the Knight here so early it's
not defended and it's a
Target by my
queen
so I think I'll go for Knight takes D4 I
don't want to take on E5 because then
the Knight can take back and I just lose
material so I'll take and if the bishop
takes and I'm going to win the piece if
the pawn takes and my knight would have
been
counterattacked um I'd probably still
win material in that line
[Music]
so I just want a knight now this could
still get interesting because black has
a move
here which attempts to win back material
uh the move
D5 but I don't think that will work okay
we see D6 um D5 would have attacked the
bishop and the queen uh but against both
moves I take on G7 hitting the Rook so
even if the pawn was on D5 there'd be no
time to take the
bishop and here we're going to show no
mercy rook's attacked and the pawn is
attacked so Rook f8 is um really the
only move and
now yeah really putting the hammer down
threatening to take on
f8 and The Rook is basically trapped
here um yeah the king the king is trying
to run away uh now it is a quest do I
want to take the
Rook or do I want to try and keep Queens
on the board and Checkmate as quickly as
possible but I'll keep it simple I'll
take the
Rook because I was already up a bishop
now I'm up rook and Bishop we're trading
Queens it will take a little bit longer
to convert this
position just naturally without having
Queens on the board it takes longer to
checkmates but again I'll try and be a
efficient uh this move F4 aims to open
the file get the Rook
involved The Rook is very happy to sign
in and there's a few strategies here uh
one of the simplest is just to consume
pawns and then use my past pawns and try
and make some
Queens uh but another strategy is to go
for an eventual Checkmate without
queening a
pawn and yeah I'm employing a very
typical endgame strategy of putting both
Rooks on opponent's seventh rank as
Rooks create a battery and how these
pawns are going to be somewhat
defenseless and this is interesting like
I could take the
Rook but I don't think there's a need I
think I'm going to just start checking
when the king moves I'm going to take
with check I'll keep taking pawns with
check there's really not much black can
do anytime I want I can take the Rook as
well but it's basically an all you can
eat buffet on the queen side I'll have
my
appetizer actually I've already had
plenty of appetizers ready for the main
course okay my opponent does not
appreciate um being an all you can eat
buffet so
so yeah
uh they disconnected looks like the game
will end before we see
checkmates uh now there there is
actually a mating idea if King C5 take
and the King goes back I wouldn't take
the pawns i' I just go straight for the
king play Rook hd7
Checkmate okay so got the win there
gained 11 rating points yeah just to
show so take with check if here it's
checkmates if here I keep
taking and yeah once I took or once I
would take all the pawns and I'd
probably take the rook and then uh just
be up a batlo the
pawns so um I think we'll do one more I
do have to go soon so next game I think
will be the last game of this
episode playing
vof rated
76 from Uruguay did not recognize that
flag so I'm black every game thus far
has been in the King's Pawn opening and
we see Pawn F3
which I'll say right away it's not a
great move uh simply because usually the
Knight likes to go to F3 but also F3
weakens this
diagonal and I'm just going to start
with Bishop to
C5 and now it's going to be very
difficult for white to Castle
efficiently with my Bishop just piercing
through the diagonal uh with Bishop C5
I'm also maybe having some ideas of
taking on G1 and then Queen H4 to win
material um so depending what white does
I'm I'm sure I'll have some
options but we see Knight E2
okay so I don't have the option to take
the
Knight and the move like Queen H4
doesn't really do too much damage right
away because white would have G3 or
Knight
G3
so I think i' much
rather develop
here uh now one plan for white is to try
and play D4 and obstruct the bishop I'm
wondering if it makes sense to to allow
it I think I'm okay allowing it I'm
going to play Knight to
F6
and yeah what this does is it creates
ideas of maybe someday taking the pawn
and E4 there are potential tactics where
imagine takes takes and then check and
then G3 and then take um maybe I can
eventually win The
Rook we see G4
uh now one tip in the opening you should
almost never combine F3 and G4 even
though the pawns create a chain and it
does look aggressive uh these pawns are
smiling from White's
perspective uh but the problem with F3
and G4 is it really weakens this
diagonal um but the question is can I
exploit it because if I take if I sack
the Knight and take one of these pawns
and then play Queen H4 white can block
with Knight
G3 so I don't think I can really punish
white
immediately as much as I would like to
but maybe the best way to punish white
is to play this move
D5 putting immediate pressure on
e4 I now have two
attackers and there's only one Defender
so we do see a
trade and now I'll take with
Knight so not only centralizing the
Knight but also looking to play Queen
H4 Knight G3 okay so
White's White's trying to make the best
of
this and yeah sometimes even if the
opponent does
some does some moves which are obviously
like not great in the opening it can
still take a lot of patience to to win
and actually this move I think is
completely fine fine prepares to develop
the
bishop also yeah Queen H4 doesn't really
do
much so let me exercise some patience
I'm just going to keep
developing like as I get more more of my
minor pieces into play
then there's going to be gradually more
pressure on White's
position so far white only has one piece
developed
and that one develop piece is moving
again Knight E4 attacking the
bishop there's a move here which I don't
think I can resist
playing and honestly it might be one of
the best moves anyway now I should note
of course I can play Queen H4 and make
the knight move back
but I have a different idea in mind I'm
going to play Knight
D4 and say oh no my
Bishop my Bishop is bait because after
the Knight takes the
bishop yeah this is
chatmate uh that was a little bit cruel
but also a little bit cool uh basically
yeah the knights um went a little bit
too far away from its defensive role and
now Knight G3 is not not quite possible
here
so that was a short and sweet game to
finish things off um the main lesson
from this game is never play
F3 as early as move two like there's no
opening I don't
think at least there's no mainstream
opening where F3 is a good move so early
likewise I I guess I'll share a quick
lesson here um let's say you're playing
white and you just play the standard
Knight F3 uh black should never play F6
in this position here it's actually even
worse uh moving the F Pawn because
there's a tactic Knight takes E5 Pawn
takes E5 and then Queen H5 and I don't
think I've had any games featuring this
yet in the speedrun but sometimes
beginners will stumble into this where
if G6 you can take and then win The Rook
nice double attack and then if King E7
um I think white is very close to mating
by force Queen diges E5 and then Bishop
C4 and then yeah the King goes out for a
little walk and yeah this is almost
Checkmate after
G5 uh Black's position is very very
Grim there's a move here H4 I know I'm
going deep down the ravit hole but it's
uh hopefully to confirm the lesson that
you should not move the F Pawn so early
it does way more damage and
good so okay I'm going to wrap it up
here uh thanks everyone for watching
hope you learned a thing or two in this
episode uh stay tuned for more if you
have questions leave them below and I'll
see you guys soon